and in committee meeting I'm going to
see the 29th of April before I go in to
see who's with us this afternoon I think
the members will join me once again to
say thank you to all the officers
involved in putting this together it's
all new to us all the way we're using
the computer and so forth I'm not a
whisky to computers I've mentioned
before and I know there are other
members who have difficulties as well
well again thank you very much and again
of course hope all your families are and
yourselves are keeping well I will run
through names
this isn't I've done this is not in
alphabetical order I will go through the
names of the planning committee and
officers and if you could say yay you're
here or whatever and please don't be
rude because we're live just to let me
know and so counsel us Steve open yes
here comes for Alan curry yes present
councillor Ruth Duckworth yes Thank You
counselor counselor Gary Taylor I
believe he may be a little bit late I'm
sand councillor risk-averse recess ski
sorry I understand you are standing in
for counsel that Dennis corrected yes
I'm here
Thank You councillor job Hayford present
chairman councillor Keith Coleman cook
frozen councillor David Hart present
counsel in de ribes present councillor
Mike Gardner present here councillor
Matthew Scott present councillor Heather
Queen councillor Patmore
I think she's around no I thought I saw
she was removed from the main thing
right for a whole fire there well I'm
obviously here officers in attendance
please
obviously I'm aware that in Livingston
is here Emily
Kennedy is still Kalyanam yes Karen I'm
here
Thank You Estelle are there any Nick
Hughes I've noticed are there any other
officers who wish to state they're here
I'm here German and Charles hungry is
also here
yes turcotte Nixon I'm sorry Charles I
saw you were there earlier thank you
right moving on if we may quarrel
details obviously obviously I have a
script as normal planning we would have
it slightly changed as which I'm sure
you would expect if you have to happen
to your duties during the meeting please
contact the Democratic services officer
on call who will attempt to assist you
today's officer on call is Charles his
number is five seven seven one eight six
his number will be included at the top
of the chat stream for your convenience
I would ask participants when you are
not speaking please to mute your
microphone this minimizes background
noises and will help everybody else who
can listen to the proceedings
microphones must only be turned on if
the Pacific precipitant the roadway has
been granted permission to speak to gain
my permission to speak please verify
briefly indicate on the chair
in the right side on the screen I would
then make a note and go back to you once
the other person has finished finish
speaking
as usual would everybody make sure that
their mobile telephones are turned to
silent and they must not use make any
calls recalled or checking emails and
cutting and conducting any other
business during this planning meeting
thank you please note that this meeting
is being live-streamed for members of
the public and following the meeting the
recording will be available on the
council's YouTube website so looking
your best please know members have
indicated to in advance as if they wish
to speak under council procedure 20.1
yes if that has changed could they say
so now please okay no members are
speaking there apologies for absence one
we are aware of which has been noted
agenda item 2 decorations of interests
members do you have any decorations
thank you agenda item 3 minutes of the
planning committee meeting on the 18th
of March 2020 do members agree that the
minutes of the planning committee
meeting held on the 18th of March 2020
be approved and signed by the chairman
for obvious reasons I cannot sign at
presence but at some stage with the
clerk I will be sorting that out do I
have a proposal please proposed that
here can you say your name please
David Hart Thank You council Hartley we
can mention your name
obviously for minion
and do I have a seconder please yes
counselor come and cook Thank You
counselor home cook if I take these as
being approved unless any member raises
an objection thank you those minutes are
approved point of information I'm going
to hand over to mr. Livingston to update
members on a point of information
regarding an agenda item for a land at
south of the Priory closed in Margate
mr. Levinson Thank You chair and good
afternoon members so one point of
clarification for members official item
for a land south of brewery close and a
measurement has been clarified in the
report which is on page 36 of the agenda
regarding the distance between the rear
elevation of 11a Canterbury Road and the
side elevation of the proposed unit 20
of the development this measurement is
11 point 2 meters approximately and not
12 meters approximately as cited thank
you Jim
thank you mr. Livingston for that item
for agenda item 4 schedule of planning
applications as we're in this situation
together any site visits will be
arranged
accordingly when it is safe to do so
the schedule of applications have upon
the clerk to read out the planning
applications for determination if the
member wishes to reserve an application
where they please
call out as she reads Clark to read out
please Emily very close margate okay for
b1 Stanley Road Margate
yes play
councillor alban and force a 45 a month
and road Ramsgate Thank You members
so moving on as we have counselors
requiring to speak on two items there
can I move to a site yeah sorry to
interrupt see I would like to speak also
on the Stanley Road application I didn't
put my microphone phone on at the time
as fine house occur which is item for
holding yes so one that wasn't thank you
I'll come back to members there but can
I have a propose of her the application
that hasn't been reserved which is item
or see the acoustic on cook thank you
could I have a seconder please David
Hart
thanks for council the heart the members
agree
great great read very is agreed in any
against any abstentions that has been
carried thank you right moving to agenda
item 4a I believe it is mister
livingstone who's going to take this on
okay
Thank You chair give you report thank
you
okay Thank You members I've just wait
for very that should have the item there
so the application is for the land south
of Briery close Margate so this is a
reserved matters application for 24
Wellings off Briery close and just to
update members since the agenda was
published we've received two additional
representations raising concerns about
the impact on dwellings living
conditions on properties adjacent in
terms of overlooking sense of enclosure
and also raised concerns about pollution
and biodiversity impact and loss of
trees on the site so the site is
outlined in red it's at the end of
Briery close so this is an application
for reserved matters approval so members
are not being asked to consider the
principle of development or the the
number of units proposed on site because
that's already got outline approval and
also not considering the use of the
access which was granted approval
through the outline only the detail
design layout scale and landscaping as
well as the appearance of the proposals
so moving through the aerial photographs
of the site so the site is the green
part of the fields here so you can see
Briery close running to the site and the
main Canterbury Road that runs from
Westgate in Margate and this is a view
from the West looking towards the site
so you can see there's existing trees on
the western boundary and southern
boundary of the site
this is a view from the Northwest
looking towards the site so again
another view of those trees and the site
so the site is surrounded by countryside
this site adjacent as shown here is is
part of the strategic allocation in the
draft local plan for the 2,000 houses at
Westgate and garland so it's surrounded
by that strategic allocation and then
this is an aerial view showing the
properties to the rear of can't be row
owes this to the site so you see this is
looking from the north to south and
again showing where it's located in
district in relation to the countryside
so this is a view looking a long Briery
close so the site is at the end of this
road so you can see the properties in
Briery close our two-story pitched roof
properties and then going along in very
close this is a view looking in the
access into the site and then turning to
the right this is a view of one a
Canterbury Road so this was one of the
first property and that sits behind
properties on Canterbury Road and then
this is a view from within the site
looking north so you can see one a
Canterbury Road the property we were
just looking at is in the center of the
image here and the other properties that
are behind properties on Canterbury Road
are located in this area here so the
proposal is for 24th weddings to be
erected all of the dwellings proposed
are two-story except for one bungalow
which is located in this area here as
indicated by the cursor it's a mix of
two and three-bedroom dwellings
predominantly semi-detached with one
set of terrorist properties down in the
southeast corner of the site and in
terms of provision of parking there are
two spaces per dwelling or off streets
that are provided with six visitor
spaces provided for the development as
well the trees that were identified on
the photos the trees on the western part
of the site and southern part of the
site are being retained as part of the
development so they're shown on the site
plan before you and as mentioned then
the total number of dwellings has been
approved that at outline and it is
considered that the density of
development has already therefore been
found to be acceptable on on this site
and so looking at the detailed design of
these properties I'm just going to go
round the site so if we start on the
eastern side of the site running north
to south and also looking at the front
elevations of the properties that face
onto the green area proposed here so at
the top of the screen there is a street
scene of the properties that are on the
eastern side of the site facing into the
spine so you can see that a traditional
formal development is being proposed
with gable ends and pitched roofs as
well as some bay windows and a Aysen
regular fenestration pattern then
looking at the image at the bottom of
the screen the two sets of properties in
the middle there are the ones that front
will impart front onto that green space
with a slight change in design of unit
number 11 which fronts on to the
internal access road on the other side
of the site and then taking the other
elevations of the properties proposed so
looking at the western properties
running north to south and also looking
at units 22 23 and 24
front onto this parking area so 23 24
and 20 22 23 and 24 on the top image
here on the screen you can see that
there's the bungalow property that's
proposed and then the same similar
design for other units fronting onto the
central area with a slight variation in
terms of materials proposed on the side
element there and then at the term of
the screen there's the street scene that
runs along the western end of the site
against similar design to the other side
of the site and so the other section I'm
going to show you is the section just
showing the side elevation of unit
number 24 and then the the side but
actually the front elevation of the
units at south of site unit 10 and unit
11 just so members can see that as well
so unit 10 and 11 are on the left-hand
side of that image which have a slight
variation and design and an hour have
tile hanging to the first floor and then
unit 24 is is here so you can see in the
background there you've got units 15 to
18 those are obviously set further much
further away in terms of the section but
you can see that the design remember 24
is slightly different in so much that
there you've got a two-story silent and
the main body of the building is is set
back so it looks looks like this so this
is one of the sort of when you come into
the site you would see the the side of
that property as you enter the site so
looking at the proposed materials for
the development its proposed to have
clay roof tiles rub brick arches it's
growing red brick around the drum but
with some tile hanging elements as well
as black rain walls good sun and black
windows so in terms of the materials
it's considered that materials proposed
would fit in with the character of the
area which is predominantly at
in design and and vernacular materials
and there is a condition which is
proposed to be put on the reserve
matters at the approval if it was to be
approved for samples of materials to be
submitted but the the type of materials
chosen is considered to be acceptable by
officers role it could be the the layout
and proposed landscaping as well as the
scale of development is considered
appropriate to fit in with the character
the area and so no concerns are raised
by officers in regard to the impact on
the character appearance of the area so
turning to the impact on neighboring
properties and this is an aerial image
showing the dwellings to the north of
the site at one a Canterbury Road
indicated and they're moving along right
to left it's number nine can be round
number nine a can't be Road and they're
eleven a cleanse B Road and 11 e
Canterbury Road so we've isolated a site
plan at this point just just to look at
this relationship particularly and so in
terms of unit 20 here so the frontage of
unit 20 fronts on to the access road so
the side elevation of this property
faces towards the rear of 11a Canterbury
Road and so moving to this image so in
the top right-hand corner of the screen
you'll see the side elevation of unit 20
and then an enlarged version at the
bottom right-hand side of the screen and
so this elevation does contain a side
window first floor however this is a
bathroom window which will be obscure
glazed and there's a condition proposed
to obscure glaze that window and
therefore it isn't considered that any
overlooking
be created from unit 22 the neighboring
property the neighboring property as
mentioned is eleven point two meters
away
it's a the property on County Road is a
is a two-story property it's considered
that given the way that the the way that
the building is is actually cited and
designed specifically that you have the
main the main bulk of the building is 15
metres away here but it isn't considered
that there will be a significant sense
of enclosure created from the
development by virtue of that
relationship or or a loss of light to
warrant refusal on that particular point
now this has been amended since the
original submission came in so this is
this has been changed to try and better
reflect the fact of its proximity to
number 11 a with those changes as well
the property here number 22 previously
were a set of two-story properties and
this has been changed to bungalow to
avoid any overlooking to the the
neighboring properties which is 9 and 9
a can't be Road to the north looking at
then units 23 and 24 so these are
two-story properties that do have
first-floor windows that face to the
north and face towards the negra
properties so one a at Canterbury Road
here this is a front garden that members
will recall from seeing the image
earlier that is open for views from
Briery close in to and there is a
distance from this property to the front
elevation of of 23 meters and so it's
not considered that they'll be direct
overlooking to warrant a significant
loss of privacy from these windows and
in the same way the distance between the
angled window in terms of the angle from
number 9 to number 23 and the bedroom
window here which I will show you on
this elevation so looking at the rear
elevation of units 23 and 24 here in
terms of the disc
is considered sufficient that it
wouldn't result in a loss of primacy to
the properties to the north from the
relationship as as designed so taking
through some of the other issues that
have come up through the reserve masters
application so the application
originally sought to discharge a number
of requirements that were put on the
outline application in relation to
archaeology and also drainage and
members will have seen from the
consultation that there are still some
outstanding issues to be resolved with
those particular points and therefore
the the conditions on the outline have
not been cleared in totality with
regards to archaeology and drainage so
they all still remain in force and
indeed there are a number of conditions
which will still remain in force from
the outline and which have not
discharged so one of them includes some
a program for enhancements and for
biodiversity purposes which is condition
15 for a program to be submitted in
regards to that as well as a tree
protection plan which is still to be
submitted these are required prior to
the commencement of development the
applicant has agreed to provide one
electric vehicle charging point for each
property as well as a provision for the
visitor spaces
which is considered to accord with the
requirements of the air quality
technical guidance and as I already
mentioned very still the samples
condition for materials so overall it's
considered that the development would be
in accordance with the character
appearance the area and would not result
in a significant impact on the living
conditions and neighboring properties
with a number of matters already
resolved to be acceptable through the
outline and therefore the recommendation
from officers is to approve the
application Thank You chef
Thank You Ian very much I move that the
officers recommendation is adopted could
I have a seconder please or second chair
Thank You council a common cook if
members wish
speak about this application please let
the clerk know or myself I do have the
debate counselor Garlin all right thank
you very much yeah I've worked out the
microphone on there
thank you well yeah I haven't I I had a
couple of questions I wanted to raise
one of which was around the ecologic
ology side which I think means the
indeed answer looking through the report
that was presented I didn't see any
mention in there of our only saw mention
there's of a landscape management plan
rather than the plan as to hell but the
ecology would be in home enhancing
biodiversity a biodiversity plan so I
think you've answered that in that they
are going to be producing that plan and
could I just clarify one thing around
the number of trees that were around the
site at the moment did you say that
there were we wrote that they weren't
going to lose any of those trees are
currently around the site in yeah
thank you and so the trees around the
edge of the site are not be opposed to
be removed so they are being retained
there are a understand there are a
number of smaller trees or self
centuries that are within the site
obviously it's it's an it's a partially
overgrown site and so they would be
removed obviously that are within that
the side the moment which was obviously
part of the approval outline um there is
a condition on the outline which
requires the submission of a landscaping
scheme specifically which is condition
20 on the outline and from the the site
plan it shows that you know there are
trees proposed to be in the middle of
the site but it's predominately the
trees around the outside which are the
more mature specimens that are being
retained as part of the development
okay and then of the I've had a look at
a number of developments around the
Westwood Crosse area where new trees
have been planted and they seem to have
just been left to to their own devices
and the number of those who have died as
a result
so with real part of this biodiversity
plan ensure that the developers who are
planting the new trees here and looking
after the biodiversity of the site
ensure that they will be maintaining and
looking after those the trees another
biodiversity for at least the first
couple of years so they become well
established yes well there are two
points actually where this is picked up
so one is picked up through the which is
condition 21 on the outline which is is
effectively looking that any trees or
plants which within five years from the
completion of the development that I
should basically be replaced in the next
planting season but also we we do feel
because there are landscaped areas that
have been proposed as part of the scheme
and that's why there is an additional
condition being put on the reserve
matters which talks about a landscape
management sort of information coming
forward to actually work out how how
those areas are being maintained going
forward okay thank you
they the other area I just wanted to ask
about was affordable housing I noted in
the report that there are I believe six
six of the houses are going to be made
available for as affordable housing but
none of the or only two of those I think
are three-bedroom houses
well now housed in a vast for more of
the the three-bedroom houses to be made
available as affordable housing this was
that considered and it's only what the
readers are why that wasn't done you
know thank you so and the in terms of
the affordable housing provision so it
was proposed to
submit that information with the
reserved matters but indeed there were
queries about the the composition of the
mix that was being offered the
unilateral undertaking which is part of
the outline application which committed
to 30% on-site affordable housing
requires the submission of an affordable
housing scheme so that is still to be
agreed so that the discussions can
continue ongoing they don't have to be
fixed within this reserved matters
approval which is why it's been taken
out of the consideration as as
identified in the report okay thank you
so if I could just just one final
question ook often when I mean we're
being asked to approve this we're not
being asked for this to be deferred for
approval later but there still are a
number of things outstanding to be
agreed
so I'll just wonder why why are we why
we've been asked to approve outright
rather than being asked to defer this
for approval when these when some of
these other matters are resolved p.m.
can you and thank you chair so as this
is a reserved matters approval this is
an application that can be approved
outright it is slightly different in the
sense of the outline has a number of
conditions that are on it which still
require submission of details to the
local authority for clearance that is
normally done through discharge of
conditional process rather than
deferring a back to offices to get that
information and all of the matters are
conditional so those submissions can
come in after the approval of of this
reserved matters application thank you
in and welcome to councillor Taylor I
know he has a certain work problems or
has to work yes thank you a time
councillor Taylor next to speak on this
matter is councillors esky
Thank You chairman as you know I'm
standing in counselor Denis today
councillor Denis asked me if I could
bring to the attention of the committee
the access to the to the site there
seems to be some query about the size of
the road leading up to it and the
easiness for lorries etcetera vehicle
access a site now I know cap that that
mr. Livingstone mentioned something
about access at the beginning I'm not
sure whether we're allowed to think
about this or not maybe he can explain
bit further on that Ian can you come
back on at all yes so the point of
access onto Briery closed was considered
as part of the outline application and
so it was one of the issues that was
looked at specifically by the inspector
and members will have seen the appended
appeal decision which was which was put
into the agenda in terms of the actual
access into the site it has been
considered by KCC as part of this
application and there are measures
within the original outline conditions
which relate to the particular concerns
that were raised for that outline about
the access onto or from briar close
particularly with regards to the
provision and installation of double
yellow line parking along Priory close
which is condition as part of the
outline as well as ensuring that all
provisions are made for the required
visibility splays and bound surfaces as
well so this matter has been covered
through the outline application
predominantly and we're only looking at
the detailed layout within this reserve
matters and the detailed design of of
the dwellings Thank You Ian would that
satisfy councillor Dennis such we think
customers Eskie he was asking whether or
not it was possible to have a site visit
to look at it but if we can't actually
change anything about the
access I don't see the point in it I
mean the layout I don't see a problem
with the layout it's purely on an access
issue I can recall this before counselor
so I think at the moment if we take mr.
Levinson's advice I say site visits
going to be very difficult as young I
know you know at the moment anyway so
thank you counselor job Hayford Thank
You chair I observed that most of the
objections to this development do relate
to the general development and the
access which as Ian's explained have
already been granted so in my view it's
quite a thoughtful development the
materials and design of the properties
are not unattractive
there is some variety it's in keeping
with the local area and in my view
subject to the outstanding conditions
and the tree protection plan I would
like to support this application thank
you Thank You councillor Beauford do we
have anybody else speak councillor Albin
yes thank you chair well actually
capsule both councillor Ghana and
councillor bauford have asked the
questions and and I totally agree with
cap capsule de Beauford so end of story
for me I will be supporting this
application Thank You chair Thank You
councillor Albin I don't believe there
are any other speakers
I'm sure Emily will correct me if I've
missed one okay I'm going to put this in
the boat and I will yes I've just got a
note come it's so clever isn't it notes
coming up on the screen I'm going to go
through this it is for approval if I go
through the names again not all in
alphabetical order but please say yes no
or abstain if you wouldn't mind
please cancer calm and cook yes
counselor Steve Albin yes for approval
chair thank you
I answered your Beaufort yes for a proof
of check counselor Alan curry yes for
approval chairman Thank You councillor
Ruth Duckworth's
yes Chad Thank You councillor Mike
Connor yes Thank You councillor David
Hart yes for approval councillor Heather
keen yes for approval chair I will try
councillor Pat Moore if she's there now
I'm here but I'm not allowed to vote
Charles told me because I came in late
thank you perhaps for that yes we
understand thank you but nice to see you
there thank you
councillor George Metesky I'll abstain
please searcher Thank You councillor
Matthew Scott yes for approval
councillor Gary Taylor came in late
Carrie so on this one
yeah I understand sure thank you then so
luck council in the right for approval
chair Thank You members if my had enough
and everything is right so that has been
approved thank you very much
moving on to the next item and I must
get these right in order item 4b so if I
could hand over to mr. Livingston please
he's disappeared
I'm still here - thank you let me just
object present my screen for this item
okay so the application site is for one
Stanley Road Margate it's to change the
use of the property which is a dwelling
into two dwellings with a single-story
rear extension proposed so the main
issues for members to consider are the
principle of development the impact on
neighboring properties the impacts on
character appearance of the conservation
area as well as the impact on highways
it is outlined or on your screen in red
so just looking at some aerial images
here so we're in cliftonville this is
Stanley Road here and with Swain Road to
the east of the site so the cursor is
indicating where this particular
existing building is so this is a 3d
image showing from Google the view of
the rear of the building in question
here and this is a view of the front of
the property itself this is a view from
Stanley road and then this is closer in
view and here is another view and you
can see there is a gate here which is
used to access the alleyway which runs
all the way along the back of properties
on Swain Road so as mentioned one of the
main issues for the application is that
it's is the principle of development so
the site is within the development plan
area for the four cliftonville
and particularly there is a policy which
is cv2 which does not permit the
subdivision of properties last used as
family family dwellings effectively and
fairly owns a constitute properties with
two or more bedrooms so the property is
a five bedroom property at the moment
this proposal in offices views would
still provide the continued use of the
main building as a five bed property
with a rear extension and access via the
alleyway to actually provide a new to
bed
dwelling at the rear of the site so you
can see on this site plan it shows that
there'll be two garden areas created
from the development so there would
still be a garden for the five bed house
which would still front that the street
with a new garden for the new dwelling
at the rear so we just move through and
show the general arrangement in a bit
more detail and so this is the proposed
site plan so the so this is sort of
turning the previous image you see on
its side so the frontage is on the
left-hand side of the image to stanley
road with the alleyway access down into
and then the main new part of the
development would be at this bit here as
indicated by the cursor to create the
two-bird property so you can see that
the two-bed property would have a garden
accessible here with the main garden for
the five bed property at the rear here
so looking at the extension itself
that's proposed this is an existing rear
elevation
of the property members will have seen
from the images the aerial images that
there are a number of extensions that
have occurred to this property over the
years and what's being proposed is for a
new single-story
addition to be included in offices views
because of where this particular
extension is locate
it's not considered to result in any
harm to the conservation area in terms
of making sure that it would fit in with
the character of the area and the
materials themselves are proposed to
match the materials on the main property
it's not highly visible because of its
location and therefore the impact on the
character and appearance of the area is
considered to be acceptable so looking
at the other side elevation probably so
this is the existing elevation of the of
the property from the alleyway so you
can see the actual scale of the building
that we're talking about even though
it's currently a five bed well it is a
large property and the extension is the
part at the rear here that that's
proposed so again it's low level and
it's not considered to have caused harm
to the character of the area so this is
the existing West elevation of the site
so you you can see that there is quite a
significant amount of two-story
extensions that are present on the
property and again this is then the
accretion proposed at the end here in
terms of the impacts on neighboring
properties the neighbor number two here
has rear windows the the rear extent of
their property but you can see from the
shaded area in this image that the
existing two-story extensions do
protrude past that rear elevation quite
significantly at the moment and
therefore even though the extension is
is 5.1 meters deep the new extension
that single-story it's considered that
by virtue of the existing relationship
as well as the fact that the extension
is actually set off the boundary that
there wouldn't be a significant harm so
this is a 3d concert image from Google
to just give you an indication of the
action ship so this is showing the
cursor the actual two-story element and
how far it extends back into the site
and
you can see here again this is with the
extension on the back of the property so
you can see that two-story extent at the
moment and then and then here is the
rear sectional elevation of the proposed
extension and you can see that it's set
off by the from the boundary by about
two point three meters so it's not
considered that there would be an impact
in terms of living conditions of the
neighboring property from the proposal
so just moving through the floor plans
just to show you the existing floor
plans so this is the existing ground
floor plan so you can see that there's a
significant amount of living space with
one bedroom at the rear and then on the
first floor you have a series of of
other rooms including two more bedrooms
but more living space and then two more
bedrooms on the second floor so as
already shown this is the proposed
ground floor so you can see that the the
living space is that in the kitchen for
the dwelling that would be retained at
the front still remains pretty much
entirely intact but it's subdivided it
at this point here with then the ground
floor of the two-story property that
would be proposed at the rear has one
bedroom at ground floor it's been shown
as a wheelchair-accessible dwelling so
you can see that the turning souks have
been shown as well as the width of the
access ways and then moving on to the
first floor plan as proposed so you see
that three of the bedrooms are retained
at the front for the front dwelling with
the to bed property at the rear again
you can see that it's got a shower room
in the in the first floor because it's
been designed to be wheelchair
accessible and then with the proposed
second floor with the two bedrooms
pretty much identical to so how it is
how it is now so in terms of the other
issues to consider
there the development would result in
the creation of a new unit
in terms of in terms of the number of
potential people living on the process
which could result in highways impacts
in terms of the area it is generally an
area that that has a lot of on Street
car parking that occurs
Stanley Road M is one of the I suppose
substrates that doesn't have quite so
much Vic Euler parking in comparison to
those streets in Clifton with north to
south and it is considered that whilst
there is an additional dwelling being
proposed
there is only actually the addition of a
couple of bedrooms worth of living
occupants that that's created and it is
considered that that that additional
single car or two cars and would not
result in a significant impact on
highway amenity or indeed highway safety
from the development now it is creating
a new unit and therefore the development
is required to contribute towards the
strategic access management and
monitoring plan which is to provide
mitigation to the impact on the special
protection area from additional
recreational pressure from population
growth and therefore the application is
is recommended for deferral for the
receipt of the unilateral undertaking to
be submitted to secure that contribution
so overall and it is considered that
there are benefits from providing an
additional family unit as the farm
budget and plan on this property it is
also been designed to be wheelchair
accessible we don't consider that it
would have an impact on the character
appearance of the area and given that
the existing large property would be
retained as a dwelling and this doesn't
result in the subdivision to create
flats it creates a new family dwelling
we do consider it is an acceptable
departure from policy CV 2 and therefore
it is recommended to be deferred for the
receipt of the unilateral with
safeguarding conditions but deferred for
approval thank you chair Thank You Ian
and maybe with the officers recommend
recommend a ssin for deferral is
approved could I have a seconder please
councillor Chesky Thank You councillor
as esky I do have two members wish to
speak at the moment councillor curry
thank you young chair the main reason I
called in this application was the
departure from the cliftonville
development plan notably policy cv 2 I
also had concerns with the side access
to the flat this would certainly cause
noise and disruption to the near
neighbours which they never had before
the bins would be located in the rear of
the property but it really is a
departure from the policy that I find
very difficult to support the policy CV
so retention of family housing states
planning permission for the subdivision
of properties currently or last lawfully
used a single family accommodation or by
a single household will not be permitted
I do it knowledge that this is a very
large property it has a very large
garden but that is one of the reasons
the development plan for cliftonville
was brought in to protect these lovely
old properties from over development and
subdivision Cliftonville west already
has I believe the highest percentage of
flats in fanon I think it's about 60%
are gates 50% or so compared to about
25% in the rest of the district
I don't think we really need another
two-bedroom flat yes for these reasons
I'll be voting against the application
Thank You chair Thank You council curry
councillor Alban yes thank you tuna
firstly I totally agree with counselor
curry in relation to policy CV to agree
veneer a question for mr. Livington
please and it's you mentioned it's a
five-bedroom house P and it says in a
rapport I just want clarification it
says it's just six bedrooms I'm just
what a clarification on that point first
please
and this that's just a story and it's
that it's just a misprint or something
Thank You Chet and yes it's is a it's a
five-bedroom property I think it is it
is a misprint there are two reception
rooms and two kitchens so it's it's got
and significantly more than five that
you'll probably normally have but it
it's not it's not got six bedrooms as
the report stays
okay thank you I think another concern
really that I have apart from the policy
issue is that effectively what we got
here is our back garden development
we're putting a new dwelling in a back
garden and and when I put that together
with councillor Curry's concerns
regarding the the issue on the cvv2
policy I think I will go along with
councillor Korean relation and I will
not be supporting this application Thank
You chair
thank our organ accounts are right
mister Thank You chair ordinarily I
wouldn't support this application either
but added to the fact that there is
disabled facilities which which we badly
need I will be supporting the
application thank you you can stay right
I'm sort of keen councillor keen I'm
looking for you it's all right okay
sorry about that technical problems and
you know I just wanted to say I will
also not be supporting this because of
the contravention of the cliftonville
plan and I think it's really important
in such an overdeveloped area that we
don't allow more development like this
thank you Thank You council keen
councillor heart
Thank You chair uh just a quick question
is this a family house or is it an HMO
in so the property I think as in the
report it describes about some of the
history of the property itself so it's
it's it's basically classification at
the moment is as a as a dwelling so it's
not it's not got consent as an HMO I
believe it has had a previous previous
different uses but it is it's a family
dwelling I think it was looking at the
history it was a hotel then it was a
children's home and it was confirmed and
changed from a hotel
to a single dwelling in 2000 looking at
the planning history so it's been a
dwelling for a significant number of
years thank you and I don't see any
other members here so I'm going to put
this to the vote for the offer the
recommendation from the officers is to
deeper once again I will go through your
names and if you could say yes no
abstain I would be grateful cast a
common cook yes captaincy wolven no
counsel to your bay furred no counselor
Alan curry no counselor Ruth Duckworth
no counselor Mike gamma no counselor
David Hart
my counselor Heather Keene no counter
Pat Moore
no counselor George Rose eski no
counselor Matthew Scott no counselor
Gary Taylor no counselor Linda Wright
can't the right yes that motion has so
and I'll come too
Ian it may first chair so I think this
is is pretty clear that members are
concerned about the fact that it's
contrary to policy cb2 of the clifton
development plan document and therefore
I think if the chair puts it to members
for a member to propose a motion for
refused on the basis of that policy then
that would sum up the concerns that
members have thank chair thank you I've
just had a note from Estelle regarding
voting I would again go against that as
well
so I mean that there's another number
okay ma'am miss you heard mr. Levinson
remarks they are and a suggestion for
refused or once again I will go through
sorry chair if you if you could put it
to the members to seek a proposed a for
a motion and then we'll move that thank
you
I think I have one already if I could
put that two members for for the
proposal of refusal under the grounds of
as mr. Vincent has stated I did see
counselor urban pop up there so cancer
or burn please you are proposing yes I
would propose that the application be
refused on the grip of it does not
comply with cliff the bill proposal for
sorry for cliftonville policy CV to
anchor if that has a bit odd
no that's mine - Thank You councilman
second a police I'll second that chair
Thank You councillor curry again I will
go through the members I know this may
look a bit long-winded but we have to do
this
those in favor of that motion which
you've heard you say you agree or not
agree council common cook not agree not
agree right so no no I'm just coming
back to you for clarification you don't
agree with the has been performed right
miss Livingston no chair because I voted
for this so therefore it would be odd
for me for now for the lemon I
understand thank you cop how's the Colin
cook casserole been yes counts of job a
foot
yes agree capsule Aaron curry yes
counselor rooks backwards yes counselor
might garner yes counselor David Hart
yes counselor Heather keen yes counselor
Pat Moore yes Elsa Georgia it is sp yes
for councillor Matthew Scott how's the
Carey Taylor yes
counseling him to write know myself yes
Thank You members and thank you mr.
Livingston and for that okay that's gone
through moving on to item four d once
again if I could hand over to Ian for
his presentation please
Thank You chair um so I'll just present
my screen to the members thank you so
the this agenda item is for a council
owned site for 19 to 21 Warwick Road is
what a member count project convert no
intentions at the front and we're in
Livingston totally
can I ask out other councillors please
to mute their microphones we cannot hear
Ian at the moment
Ian if you can hear me we can't hear you
can now right Oh hopefully you can hear
me now so and you can also see the image
for the site which is outlined in red so
this originally was a council project
which came before members to convert the
hotel into nine to bed flats with the
removal of extensions at the front and
the rear what members are considered
during is a minor non-material amendment
application to make some changes to the
development as already approved and so
this is an image from last year from
Google Street View just showing the
front of the site and when it loads up
hopefully you'll see the image there we
go which shows the front of part the
site now so there was previously a
rather large single-story
the front of the property and it's now
been removed with a new bays constructed
as part of the development so what in
this was the east or this was the
existing elevation as originally it on
in city on site and then this was the
approved scheme so the proposed change
is to remove some ramps at the front of
the property that originally approved so
the ramps in that this location here are
on the image and also to the rear and
the reason why it's proposed to remove
these ramps is because the internal
levels have been changed in the building
so that all entrances are currently
wheelchair accessible so there's no
longer a need for those ramps to be
present it's also proposed to make - to
not make some external changes to the
facade of the building and to retain the
brickwork as shown on the frontage and
not render the property at the first
first floor levels so the question for
members for this PureApplication is
whether or not the changes proposed
under section 96 a are non-material or
not having regard to the effect of the
change on the original development and
it's considered that by virtually the
two particular things that have changed
the fact that the entrances are still
wheelchair accessible and they're
removing alterations at the front and
also keeping the existing materials
exposed as on the building at the moment
that therefore those changes are
non-material to the development and
therefore the recommendation is that the
application should be approved thank you
thank you in my mistake earlier that is
a gender item 5 minus here so apologies
if anybody who's got confused there I
move that the officers recommendation is
adopted and that is to approve could I
have a second to please or second that
Thank You counselor Oh said something
very wrong counselor cook do you wish to
debate this members I've seen no nothing
come up on my screen
so I will go through the names once
again so if you approve yes you're
against no and if you stain please say
so
counselor common cook yeah announcer
Albin yes counselor favorite counselor
curry yes counts duckworth yeah
counselor is X T yes counselor Ghana yes
counselor hard yes counselor keen yeah
I'm sort of more yes counselor Scott yes
counselor Taylor yes and myself yes
have I missed anyone Thank You that has
carried if by paperwork and everything
else is correct which I hope it is that
brings the end of our first sorry
counselor right didn't vote I can't sir
right um the arias Thank You counselor
right as I say yeah on my paperwork here
that does conclude I'm sure I be told on
here
I guess the motion is carried by the way
I know I have to look at my screen as
well and it pop now you gather I'm
getting to know how it works
that does conclude this first meeting of
planning the way we're using everything
uh I hopefully um it's gone well and I
think all members as did earlier on
and the staff and officers for all the
background work that we can't see but
they're keeping an eye on us
because I think we all know this has to
be conducted correctly so members that
say good afternoon to you please say
safe and till the next